I had an experience the other day
with this song where the song literally
spoke to me it spoke to me there was a
reality bleed through effect quite
common common characteristic of music
when it really slays you there's a
reality bleed through effect where all
of a sudden the music speaks to you you
know the psychologist Jordan Peterson he
talks about these moments as moments
where the objective world and the
narrative world the lyrical world the
poetic realm touch
when the objective world and the
narrative World touch music seems to
literally speak to you but how does this
even begin to make sense the song was
recorded maybe decades before you were
born decades before this moment decades
before your particular objective
biographical reality and yet somehow as
if in a dream the right song in the
right moment will speak to you
what is this experience
is this what they call the Holy Ghost
is this a kind of healthy psychosis a
kind of waking up into the tops of Turvy
World in which music speaks to you like
voices in your head what do we speak of
when we speak of these moments
when the objective world and the musical
world and the Cinematic World touch well
I think it's revealing of an archetypal
kind of collective space in which we
live our Mythic life which sits above
our biographical life it is the life
that is made real during a guitar solo
it is the collective effervescence as
Emily durkheim described that you feel
among your compatriots during the
climactic song in the concert that takes
your breath away the time of serious
dancing and in these moments the music
literally speaks to you and every
every quality of its sensorial assault
upon your senses fits your unfolding
fits your cognitive unfolding in your
mind's eye the film is climaxing with
realization you're having a moment of
salience in cinema we create montages to
try to render to showcasing an
illustrative fashion the subjective
experience when music speaks to you
Cameron Crowe the filmmaker behind
Almost Famous the writer director and
former Rolling Stone journalists
understands this well which is why his
film Almost Famous is a love letter not
just to music but to the Divinity that
pulses through its Melodies moments like
sitting in the back of the bus singing
hold me closer tiny dancer among those
you love the most or moments on stage or
Moments in Love of or when Penny Lane
comes into your room wearing nothing but
a fur coat and says ladies and gentlemen
or the scene where she's
roller skating Barefoot in the Afterglow
of the previous night's concert while
listening to the wind it is these
moments where music literally speaks to
us we're movies literally speak to us
and I want to live there and bathe
myself there and be filled to the brim
with the beauty of life that opens up
and transpires in these places and
spaces the truth beyond the literal grid
the thing which shall not be spoken
cause you have to go there to know there
what's it like to lose yourself in a
guitar solo dad son you have to go there
to know there one day it'll happen and
you look at me
and you'll know
so I guess the question is
[Music]
what are you gonna do with this
information
you're gonna go out there and eat art
the way that plants eat Starlight you're
gonna go out there and live in your eyes
and your ears like my buddy Jason
Goodman are you just gonna eat the
aesthetic realm are you just gonna live
in the realm of aesthetic ecstasy and
soft Fascination I say hallelujah yes
Soul Force baby aesthetic arrest The
Place Beyond the literal grid the edge
of the wave the tunnel
tunnel the flow action subject and
process become one thing whoa whoa
you're just
your past is exploding behind you your
Footprints are being washed from the
shore it's a not depletive
non-extractive act done solely for the
pleasure of the act itself and that and
that is the destiny of man
and that is the destiny of man and that
is the destiny of man
that is the destiny of man
[Music]
you'll see them
[Music]
[Music]
sing at the world
foreign
[Music]
yeah oh Lord Oh Lord
oh Lord
oh Lord
Oh Lord
there's a star man sitting in the sky
he'd like to come to Earth but he's
afraid he'll scare you
yeah baby yeah
bow
bow bow